everyone my name is Adam Ryan I'm the
vice president media for the hustle I
have the the pleasure of introducing our
next speaker who most of you probably
know if you're here you definitely know
the company that he's created sampar has
been a lifelong entrepreneur he started
with a chain of hotdog stands in
Nashville Tennessee and now oversees the
entire hustle operation in San Francisco
and Sam started the hustle in his
kitchen creating content that was for
the purpose of community and since then
the hustle has now grown to 500,000
subscribers in our email with
industry-leading
industry-leading engagement millions of
people to our site every month events
like this one all across the country and
has had the opportunity to hire 17
people while keeping a profitable
business that whole time what hasn't
changed is the process of how we create
content and and how we do that on a
daily basis so without further ado Sam
par to teach you how we have done that
for the last couple years when I first
started this company I promised I would
never speak at my own conference but on
Tuesday Kara asked me to help her out
and give a talk because a lot of people
had asked about this topic and so here I
am I'm breaking my first rule so but
that's okay so today what I'm going to
talk about is the really really boring
stuff that everyone should think about
and use if they actually want people to
read their writing and what's what's
interesting about this topic is that
it's like I said pretty boring but the
results are what are incredibly useful
and so before we get into this I'm gonna
I'm gonna assume a couple things and
this is who this talks for first it's
for people who are novice to medium
novice to intermediate when it comes to
writing how many of you are doing
content marketing because you have
something else that you want to sell
okay how many of you are in the media
space where you're just what you you
that is what you're selling is your
media
okay perfect that that's what I was
hoping for so most people are in here
because they they have a product that
they try to sell and they're trying to
get traffic to convert those users so
that that's perfect and the last thing
is that the assumption here is that you
actually want to influence action and
get people to read what you're gonna
what you're creating now I have to I
have to do a quick disclaimer which is
so when we started the Hustle originally
what we were is we we're now an email
that's what we do we have half a million
people on our email list but when we
first started we were a blog and the
idea was we want to create this blog in
order to get a lot of email subscribers
because we don't have a lot of money so
we couldn't pay for it so we just had to
use our time and I am NOT a writer I did
not study journalism we have people who
have at our company but that's not me
and so I never considered myself a great
writer but what I was always pretty good
at was captivating people's attention
and so I studied a ton of books a ton of
principles and I thought what what makes
people share what grabs people's
attention how are the tactics how does
that actually work and so what we ended
up creating over the years is a process
that helps people go from an idea to
putting it on paper I'm not going to
talk about how to get traffic because a
lot of people go do that but I'm
literally just gonna talk about the the
idea of going from idea to paper because
it's incredibly important because a lot
of people have really good ideas they
just suck at going through the process
and although I hope that what you hear
me saying makes me sound incredibly
intelligent but the truth is I didn't
make any of this stuff I'm just stealing
it from a ton of different sources and
we put it together into our process now
before we get into all this I want to
let you know that I always feel that the
point of getting someone to read
something is to make them feel an
emotion because the most emotion is what
causes action I also won't love using
first-person a lot of who here works at
a company that's over a thousand people
okay cool so if it looks about a third
of you so if you are one of those people
a lot of times you're gonna get
chastised for using first person for a
quote sounding not professional
I think that's crap I think that you can
write in a conversational way while also
being incredibly professional and when I
think of content I think of your
creating a journey almost like you're
writing an episode of loss and that's
how I think of this this style of
content where there's lots of ups and
there's lots of downs and you're leading
people through this emotional journey
because in the end that's how you're
gonna get people to act so here's the
process that we've created now the
hustle when we first started it was we
couldn't afford to hire experienced
people and so this is the process that
we use to train people who were pretty
talented but not refined now that we
have some more experienced people
working things have shifted a little bit
but if you're gonna implement this
process if you just do this it'll work
fine it will work very good and you'll
be good to go after a while then you can
make your own process but if you just
copy this it'll work wonderfully and
today what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
through an example of one of our very
first blog posts we ever wrote was about
a guy named Josh Shelton who lived on
Soylent for 30 days if you googled the
hustle soil it you'll see this article
you'll see exactly what I'm talking
about
but I'm gonna use this article as an
example of this process and we're gonna
write this we're gonna rewrite this
article has anyone read this cool so
basically the idea is Soylent it's a New
Age meal replacement and it wasn't meant
to live off of but we wanted to make a
splash and so we said we basically gave
this guy $2,000 and he said are you
would you be willing not to eat anything
for 30 days and only drink this and blog
about it and he said yes so let's start
with the headline like I said I told you
the idea of the article which was the
one-liner was we're gonna get a guy to
live on so that for 30 days that's a
fine place to start now a lot of people
what they do is they write something and
then they add the headline that's not
the right way to do it because the fact
is is that most people find their
content on Facebook or search how do you
find that through the headline the
headline is gonna be read by ninety five
percent of people the actual content by
five percent of the people that's just
the number so let's put a lot more
effort into the
so it all starts here with the headline
for the Soylent one we originally said
we're gonna go 30 days living only on
toilet that's not gonna be the end
headline that's just where we're gonna
start that's the idea
so you're gonna describe what you're
writing about in the headline in one
sentence now it actually goes a little
bit further we're gonna actually go to
the description if you guys go through
Facebook you're gonna see there's gonna
be a photo there's gonna be a headline
and then there's gonna be a one sentence
description I think it's a hundred and
ninety characters 150 but basically it's
one to two sentences that describes a
little bit more in depth what your
article about so originally we were
thinking about productivity so a lot of
people particularly my nerdy friends who
are engineers they're always trying to
maximize productivity and so we thought
let's just take this to the extreme and
so an attempt to become the most
productive person on the planet we are
gonna give up food and live entirely off
Soylent this article is about how it
went I just in two seconds I got your
attention with the headline by the
high-level what it's about and I gave
you a little bit more in the description
so what you can do is you can get a
Google Doc and you can literally just
get a Google Doc you write the headline
you write the description now it's time
to write the first draft this is where
people really screw up writing something
is and putting it on the internet with
your name on it it's a lot different
than writing code and putting it online
or it's a lot different than being a
sales person because maybe only one or
two people see it writing is incredibly
scary because potentially millions of
people can see what you've done and
because of that when people write their
draft or when they start writing their
blog post they get really stuck like
they'll write a sentence and they'll go
back and we'll delete it and then about
half an hour goes by and they'll really
only have two sentences down and they're
like these two sentences are perfect now
let's go through the rest and that's
just incredibly inefficient and so what
we tell people is make your first draft
horrible so you literally just write so
you could say this is verbatim what you
can do verbatim what you can write right
now I'm writing about Soylent and how it
went
I'm not sure what I'm gonna say so I
guess I'll just start in the beginning I
started doing sterlet for this reason
and that reason that reason you
literally can write that in your first
draft you just have to write anything
the reason being is once you have motion
evidence anyone heard the phrase motion
create seem
this is what you tell salespeople in
their phone they say like talk like walk
like this when they're when they're
trying to sell something because when
you actually start moving it gets it
gets things flowing same thing with
writing so you you just want to start
with a first rap and you just want to
write everything it's gonna be horrible
just accept that it's gonna be horrible
and accept that no one no one is going
to see that first draft now you guys are
gonna have access to the slide I
actually linked the Soylent Post first
draft in the slide deck so you can go
ahead and see it but you'll see it's
really bad now this is another part that
is not intuitive to most people which is
the incubation period has anyone ever
heard of like the idea of shower
thoughts or you're in the shower and
you're just like washing your hair or
something and it just like hits you you
just have this you have this thought
that happens quite a lot right there
there's actually a reason behind this
it's called um I believe it's called
them forgetting fixation so basically
the idea is when you're like your mind
could only think of a handful of things
at once and you're incredibly incredibly
in-depth thinking about this one topic
it's really hard to deviate even a
little bit which makes it difficult to
solve that problem because your own
you're going through the same solution
no is this solution gonna work no is
this solution go to work and yours think
about the same stuff in reality the
answer it could be just a little bit
over here but it's really hard because
you're so deep and so what this
incubation period does it allows you to
kind of expand a little bit and you can
have all these other ideas flow through
and so what we do is you write your
first draft it's gonna be horrible
if you have an hour then take an hour
and you literally just get up and you
just kind of walk around and you just
you literally just walk around and think
or you go and eat or if you're at home
you go take a shower I mean you could do
whatever you want yeah sometimes the
incubation period if you're a deadline
it could be five minutes other times
there's me people who have started
writing movies working on a script and
they come back to it two years later
because they just like they had a light
bulb moment but just going through the
incubation incubation period is
incredibly important so we're gonna get
to the editing now this is where the
important stuff all happens has anyone
heard of Ogilvy Mather it's it's like a
I don't know how big is it maybe four or
five thousand means huge four or five
thousand people I mean it's got to be
one of the biggest ad agencies in the
whole world well
Davida movie has a very famous book or
many famous books and one of my favorite
lines is he's he said that this guy's
one of the most famous copy writers of
all time and he goes I'm a famous I'm a
horrible copy writer but I'm incredibly
good at editing why because editing is
where you take something that's crap and
you turn it to gold and so you can see
here with the with the Soylent Post we
actually we start cutting everything I
mean like you will have us will have a
post that starts with two thousand words
and he'll end it a thousand words I was
talking to Michael from courts back
there and he was telling me that
sometimes I'll have someone do five
paragraphs and I don't only actually use
one of them for a story and so editing
is where the where the real magic
happens now let's dive in deeper into
that how do you edit well the first
thing that I like to do is I tell our
writers you need to create a slippery
slope the goal the first sentence is
always to get someone to read the second
sentence the goal the second sentence is
always getting them to read the third
sentence it's incredibly important that
you get people to slowly go deeper and
deeper deeper into your story that's why
I said it's kind of like an episode of
loss have you noticed how like on like
an MTV like my girlfriend watch this
watches the show all the time on MTV
where you they like are trying to meet
they're like magic or they're trying to
like meet theirs meet their boyfriend or
girlfriend I forget what it's called but
uh I noticed that they always end like
right before the big reveal there's like
a commercial break why they're getting
people go down their slippery slope
that's kind of what you have to do with
writing you want to get them to go
deeper and deeper and deeper so how do
you do that well with this Soylent post
the fact that Soylent is basically like
a slim pass but for male nerds that's
not like I love Soylent by the way so
it's like I I could make fun of it the
fact that like that it's slim-fast for
men like male nerds that's not really
that interesting but the idea of living
on it that's kind of cool and so that's
the start and then actually explaining
what it is that's the second bit and how
do we do that well we say like here's
what I'm gonna tell you about today but
first let me tell you about this that's
the first way in which we've created the
slippery slope
and then we can't we're constantly doing
that so you'll see that I'll say like
but here's the gist or but first or let
me tell you this before we get into it
and then you like get some of the some
of the meat in there and then you add a
little more spice like okay now let's
get back to the original question why
would I do that
so we're constantly adding these things
in because if this article started out
with soya is a New Age meal replacement
that's pretty much slimfast for young
nerds and people are drinking it now in
this article I'm gonna tell you about
why I lived off of it that's not going
to really punch you and if you remember
we want to get people to feel emotions
during this during this article so not
the next thing we do in order to after
we've done the slippery slope is we want
to cut like crazy usually the the
blanket rule that I've give people is
more likely than not you're gonna cut
the first 25% and you're probably gonna
cut the last 25% and you're gonna have
somewhere right in the middle one of my
favorite like I said I pretty much have
stolen all my brilliant thoughts but my
one of my favorite writers in his book
called the on writing Stephen King you
guys should all buy that's called on
writing by Stephen King he talks about
how you need to cut you kill your
darlings and so that's kind of we're
telling our writers you have to kill
your darlings and it's really hard for
people because what they think is when
they write their first draft that's
automatically what's gonna be in the in
their article but in reality their first
draft is they're just getting all the
junk out in the open and then they're
gonna find the gold in there and so you
actually want to cut most or don't be
afraid to cut a lot of stuff and the
reason being is the sharper your text is
the sharper your copy is the harder it's
gonna punch and the more emotions gonna
make someone feel and the more likely
they'll do whatever you want them to do
so how do you start cutting well the
first thing is you want to make your
first sentence punch someone in the face
that's what I always tell people it's
gonna be really sharp if you notice when
I started this talk my title of the talk
it at least caught definitely caught
people's attention or at least I hope it
did and that was the goal with the
Soylent post it was I spent the last 30
days eating nothing but Soylent a New
Age meet a New Age meal replacement why
would I do something so stupid well that
seems like it's going to grab someone's
attention as opposed to Sonia
New Age Miller placement it's important
for this reason of that reason I lived
off of it and one thing that I hate
about the reason why I'd never
considered myself a writer is when I
remember being in eighth grade and my
teacher saying you have to write an
eight hundred word essay and I want you
to you I want you to describe like the
smell of this flower and I want you to I
want you to describe what the day was
like and I found myself just filling up
space with all these ridiculous words
that I never talked about or that I
never used like like when I when I tell
someone about a story I usually I'll say
something like so I said to the guy this
this and this I don't say like well I
stood up there and I stated this this
and this like that why am I gonna write
like that let's just seems silly and so
it's incredibly important to write
simple the New York Times is about in a
ninth grade reading level USA Today is
about a fourth grade reading level we
always have our writer stick between six
to eighth grade reading level and how do
you do that well there's a app called
Hemingway app comm it's totally free you
put your text in there and they'll tell
you what reading level you're at again
to quote on writing by Stephen King any
word you got to look up and I always
struggle to say this words I'm
embarrassed to say it out loud thesaurus
I don't know the thoris any word that
you have to look up in that big don't
use so with the Soylent Post well this
was actually in a fourth grade reading
level if you read the article it's been
shared probably 15,000 times you don't
sound stupid at all or the article
doesn't sound stupid at all it sounds it
sounds very insightful and it's
intelligent in the article he talks
about philosophy
stoicism all this is great important
incredibly insightful stuff but it's
written in a way that I can talk to my
mother or I could talk to a ten-year-old
and they'll both grasp it that's
incredibly important this is actually
something that I learned from courts and
I talked to Michael about this before
this talk and he agreed that or he told
me this is still what they do but it's
in my opinion and you could once you
learn how to once you get much better at
this you can deviate but most posts I
like to keep them below 500 words or
above 1500 words
quartz has wonderful data that shows why
this is the case for shorter were
shorter articles they're not always
going to ring for search but they're
really really good for social longer
articles are a little bit better for
search a lot of people have different
reasonings why they why they make a link
they make their length a lot of it I
believe comes back from when you're in
eighth grade and your teacher told you
how to be 500 words so they assume 500
words equals quality or they assume
length equals quality that's just not
that's just false that's wrong just
because something is long does not mean
it's good and I also like to use short
sentences and short paragraphs I'll get
even more specific with this I think
that most paragraphs should be between
two and four sentences and most
sentences 25 words or less one of my
favorite books to read it's incredibly
nerdy but it's a letters to Berkshire
Hathaway shareholders so it's basically
when did it start maybe 1965 or
1960-1961 Buffett you can buy this big
old fat book and it's Warren Buffett
it's all of his letters to shareholders
Warren Buffett we can all agree is at
least incredibly intelligent at most a
genius or at best a genius so he's
intelligent and what I've actually spent
time doing this is a very nerdy thing as
I documented the average word per
sentence and over the years it's gotten
shorter and shorter and shorter and
shorter and so you've got a guy like
Warren Buffett who's trying to explain
people how the insurance industry works
cuz he owns Geico and the average length
per sentence is 18 words and so the
reason why is not only is it incredibly
you want things to be simple to read
look at this text tell me what which is
gonna be more approachable Mike I keep
referencing Michael but his are his talk
he talked about readability which one of
those is going to be more intimidating
to read
it's secondly or not secondly but to
further the point of being simple and to
make people feel and I actually am a
victim of this I do this all guilty of
this I do this all the time a lot of
people use adverbs a lot they do this
because this is again another stupid
thing that you're told to do at eighth
grade but in reality it's it's you don't
need to do it you can have some adverbs
for sure but you don't want to have too
many adverbs the reason being is it
softens your point so like one of my
favorite books Great Gatsby if you go
and read that book it'll say something
like she felt great this made him feel
wonderful you don't need a lot of these
ly words because they make you they make
you sound they make your point they soft
in it big time I think that uh and I
love quoting Stephen King because the
book had a big big influence in my life
he believed it's he's the one who said
this but it's basically the road to hell
is paved in add in adverbs so now back
to the headline so what we've done in
this process is we created our headline
we create our description we wrote our
draft we went back and we edit it and so
we have a pretty good piece of work now
what we're gonna do is go back to your
headline that headline that you
originally wrote probably doesn't
accurately describe your article anymore
or maybe it does but you could have gone
made it a little bit better but we're
gonna go back to the headline similar to
the draft of just getting just dumping
out a ton of stuff and finding gold
that's all we're gonna do our headline
right 25 of them literally in a dock run
out 25 headlines then you could do like
there's software that you can do we can
like post all 25 of them and someone
will like it'll like tell you which ones
best based off like a thousand people
voting you don't need to do that just
write it all out send it to your front
of Facebook or a messenger what I always
use or to your peers sitting next you
turn your screen and say pick one of
these which ones do you like do that to
the person next to you that's probably
good enough and so that's gonna be your
new headline so in the case with this I
wrote up there any headlines and the one
number seven so that what happened when
I went 30 days without food that's the
one who won that that one I actually in
real life I didn't pick this one until
like number 25 because when you have to
do 25 you get past a whole bunch of crap
and then you start getting more creative
and then you get to maybe number 15 18
20 and then you start finding some gold
after a while at this point I'm pretty
good with headlines I can kind of write
maybe three four or five but for a long
time I really wrote 25 headlines every
single time then we're gonna pick our
image a lot of people struggle with
picking an image because they don't
realize how important it is so not every
image needs to be a shirtless guy like
this because that doesn't fit every
every brand but you have to make your
image great a lot of people use really
boring logos or they use stock images of
like like you know like what I'm talking
about it's like like a woman wearing
like a suit and it looks - a man wearing
a suit with mugs and they're like
shaking hands yeah you know what I mean
like it's stupid don't do that it's so
in order to make it better a really
simple thing is you can use Google
basically search Google click tools
click photo size use large the truth is
is that you could be breaking a couple
copyright rules by using someone else's
image but you might get away with it if
you're a little bit bigger of a company
like we have actually just started to go
through this which we we try not to use
images because I don't want to get sued
but you can get away with it you're
small but but if you really want to do
this the right way go to unsplash.com
they have literally tens of thousands of
wonderful images they're all
high-quality you'll see it
and in terms of traffic I'm not gonna
touch too much on traffic because I know
other people gonna talk about it but
Facebook is the most important we have a
chill I have a joke in my office I hope
no one works there but I call I call it
Twitter [__] because we never get
traffic from Twitter no one gets traffic
from Twitter sorry does anyone work here
at Twitter okay sorry it's wonderful for
a lot of other reasons for getting
traffic it sucks but hey look my twitter
handle is down there the same part you
could tweet I mean we talk but don't
send me an article because like most
people no one's gonna click on it so the
way you optimize for Facebook is you
have to have a wonderful image and we
talked about the headline then we talked
about the description you're already in
the mindset of optimizing for Facebook
ask some of these other people who are
talking and they'll probably agree that
80% of their traffic maybe 90% of the
traffic that comes from social is coming
from Facebook and finally if you need
inspiration one of my favorite things is
to do to do is called copy work so the
idea here being when you does anyone
here play piano who plays piano you play
piano when you learn how to play piano
did you start by writing your own songs
or did you start by playing jingle bells
jingle bells right there's a reason for
that it's really hard just like not know
anything and then just start creating
your own thing instead you want to copy
other people because you start seeing
the texture you start feeling how things
are done so when you play jingle bells
you just kind of do it and then let's
say you want to be you want to play rock
and roll so then you start copying food
fighter songs and then let's say you
want to learn funk you start playing
James Brown you're like oh my gosh rock
and roll I see this chord structure it
always goes from like a B D like I see
this I see this pattern and then you see
this other pattern you start seeing all
these amazing patterns and you start
getting the feel of it and then you're
like I know the way in which a great
song is put together and so a same thing
with writing what I did one time I
locked myself in a room pretty much for
six months I found all of my favorite
marketing campaigns I spent about two
hours a day I wrote them all out by hand
this is called copy work this is a very
famous technique that is a proven way of
learning
humans are phenomenal at learning music
and this is the exact process in which
they do
we don't do it for riding anymore but
they used to do it in America in the
1800s or so in the up until the mid 1900
so this was actually a way in which a
lot of people learn how to write if you
read about Judd Apatow he's the director
of a lot of like stoner movies pretty
funny stuff he did this as well he would
write out SNL scripts a lot of authors I
know a few authors that would write out
Hunter s Thompson books because they
liked his voice not everyone wants to
dedicate hours a day to do this you
don't need to necessarily but if you're
stuck find your favorite blogger or find
a great artist or a great writer who you
like in or or at least who you want to
sound like and just write a handful of
their paragraphs or handful of their
sentences and that's gonna get you in
the mood at least when you'll start
seeing how it's done if you want to
become a world-class writer or at least
pretty good do this for a long time
you'll see big differences it takes a
ton of work it's incredibly boring but
it's it works
and finally our final product so this
article we posted it I don't know now
maybe a year and a half ago you'll see
the dates on there but doing this
technique this article got seen by about
half a million people it gets viewed all
the time and this is the process that we
do sometimes this process will take a
day or a big piece sometimes I'll I
could do it in 30 minutes but this is
the process that we use for writing and
it works pretty well so hopefully this
has helped you guys and I'll be around
we'll talk about later
thank you
you